arthur
dans dragon
un bien dont l'ont convaincu me disant
qu'on a plus vu son pif il et cannelle
fils pendragon le sait tous évidemment
qu'il est pas mort ça fait dix ans que
je vais finir aux salsifis mon dieu par
tous les saints non non non non
commencés pas je suis absolument pas
royer besoin de se lever
à ce niveau là cela retrouver le jeu
vous fait tous pendre par les parties
bon alors c'est très constructif
la résistance ça vous dit quelque chose
allez hop
relisez ça pouvait être intéressant
d'organiser une rencontre avec les
représentants de la résistance vous
entendez quelque chose et hâtive avec
une voix ton qui gagnent dire vous
entendez quelque chose pour faire
quelque chose de complètement informel
n'est pas possible d'être largué voilà
moi ça se passe cette petite résistance
bon vous faites deux cent pas sur le
chemin et vous monter la garde au cas où
quelqu'un rapproche approche sur le
chemin
vous faites deux cent pas sur le chemin
et vous monter la garde et si la
personne qui approche suppose revient
non vous monter la garde
il y aurait moyen de réduire la voilure
sur la connerie
de fils pendragon est de retour à bec
qui viennent
il faut tuer arthur vous savez pas faire
ça va entraîner les troupes
un télésiège eux
je ne faisais pas impensable
bah oui mais j'en prenais pas des
débiles qui j'entretenais des débiles
mais pas de débiles comme ça
qu'est ce que vous entendez exactement
pas vous êtes de retour dès fois que
vous redevenir roi quoi oui oui bah c
c'est vrai que ça fait envie quoi voir
maintenant si vous ne sentez pas vous le
sentez pas
[Musique]
coût
ce
magasin
[Musique]
il m'a sauvé la vie
pourquoi ce que j'ai vu dans ton regard
sens de l'honneur
[Musique]
j'ai une dette de sang envers toi
depuis 600 ans notre clan maintient la
paire japon
aux côtés de nos alliés
les jo
rejoindre
j'ai besoin de guerriers comme toi pour
lutter contre un cobra c'est quoi que
moi la plus grande organisation
terroriste au monde
ils vont déclencher une guerre
désolé que c'est pas mon combat alors
pourquoi tu es ici
[Musique]
on a tué mon père quand j'étais gamin je
n'ai pas de maison
je me fais appeler snake eyes
parce que je n'ai jamais eu une chance
je ne peux pas te donner un an ni à
passer mais je veux donner
un sens à ta vie
[Musique]
je continue de croire que c'est une
erreur tu penses que je mettrais ce que
en danger
cobra aura ta peau
[Musique]
je sens que je t'apprécie yonne un petit
peu
tu l'as pas vu venir celui là
[Musique]
geste
snake eyes
au cinéma c'est là que tout a commencé
la légende de candy man il se baladait
dans le quartier il distribué des
friandises aux enfants
un jour des enfants ont trouvé des lames
de rasoir dans leur bon droit
la police a débarqué c'est là que j'ai
vu le vrai visage de la peur un genou
des mathématiques ils l'ont tabassé
torturé et tué
sans sommation
quelques semaines plus tard d'autres
lame de rasoir ont apparu dans d'autres
bons mots il était innocent donc il
existe quand iman n'est pas un homme
candy man c'est toute la rue
si tu es venu chercher candy man
un bon conseil laisse tomber
je me sens en phase avec cette histoire
c'est écoutes
c'est ici dans ce quartier
que la légende est née
et la légende raconte que si on dit son
nom cinq fois en vous regardant dans un
miroir dont on peut faire apparaître on
invoque candy man or des questions
quand dimane anthony non quand il part
est je veux pas commencer à flipper dans
le nouvel appart avant de dormir quand
les noirs ont assez de problèmes comme
ça
non il faut oser arrête toi l'un des
garçons n'ont pas intérêt à dire le
dernier candidat si vous voulez faire
partie de l'histoire non
dit son
camp dit mano
[Musique]
tony
anthony qu un venu
qu'est-ce qui se passe anthony ce
quartier hanté
je crois qu'il fait le meilleur jeu les
graviers candide mann
heat avait choisi il avait un projet
pour toi
tu
es nouveau ici
il faut dire qu'en des maritimes
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'était
on l'a 26 mineurs coincés sous terre qui
vont vite manquer d'air il me faut 100
mètres de tuyaux à leur livrée en moins
de 30 heures c'est possible ou pas
ouch
je monte une mission sauveteurs
on y va
si jamais il parvient à faire
on sera mis sur la sellette
mais victime d'un sabotage
les personnels
j'ai la rage maintenant
c'est sympa bon
tahar est patente aura pas atteint la
mine
pour la griffe accroche-toi
rose cornet général de vous voir
[Musique]
chaque fois qu'une guerre est gagnée le
plus dur reste à faire maintenir la paix
c'est bien ça depuis cinq ans humains et
pilote cohabitent plus ou moins
pacifiquement
mais plus maintenant
si nous ne trouvons pas une solution
nous aurons trois milliards de morts sur
les bras mais nous avons déchiffré leurs
données de navigation
nous lançons le premier vol habité
direction leur monde vous pouvoir vous
permettre d'interagir avec les
technologie extraterrestre
je tiens à vous avoir à bord
l'heure est venue de leur rendre la
monnaie car pièce
c'est tout
donc vous avez une moitié plein ouais au
mieux
mesdames et messieurs je vous présente
cobalt s'il ya le moindre mouvement
brûlé tour
ya du mouvement vers le mur nord de
signature
c'est quoi
on est cerné
ou est-ce que l'extermination de
l'humanité nous devons absolument
repousser nos limites
je suis consciente des dangers
je suis prête à me sacrifier
le mettre fin ce bordel il ne croit pas
que
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sweeney
les amis c'est à nous maintenant outils
stable j'avais de grands shows de
grandes idées mais moi j'ai des normes
et des avec les plus hauts
vous connaissez calloway que les
calloway vie comme un reclus personne
l'a vu depuis quinze ans je vous donne
trois semaines pour me présenter un show
parfaitement huilé je ne vous décevrai
pas monsieur et vaudrait mieux sinon je
vous balance du toit
j'ai toujours rêvé de me produire avec
certitude que je suis toute petite
nos limites ici on n'a qu'à
rez-de-chaussée qui pas d'embêter à
traquer la vie commune ce triste
les pointures les pointes je ne vois pas
de réponse du tout voici ma fille
porsche à elles vont rencontrer calloway
elle est fan mon assistante est en route
pour le rencontrer en ce moment m
[Musique]
votre destination sur votre droite sur
ma droite ça marche
si tu pouvais me donner des leçons dans
ce qu'une sauverait la vie comment je
peux savoir qui était pas un type joly
comment je peux savoir c'était rigolo
[Musique]
quand
je savais que tu étais chou budget et
16h 19h fait et maintenant la star de
notre spectacle
rosita
je peux essayer non non non non
et
alors elle serait jamais capable de
jouer ce personnage c'est peut être
mieux je vais écrire un autre rôle
rosita
voilà clay calloway allez vous aime la
musique ne vous manque pas vous n'avez
qu'à recommencer à jouer non je ne veux
pas je n'ai plus entendu une seule de
mes chansons depuis plus de 15 ans et
pour une très bonne raison
coiffeur
[Musique]
les
chansons vos quartiers
à
chanter
il ne reste plus qu'une seule issue pour
toi vraiment d'elle
fait de grand et magnifique raid
c'est ce que j'ai toujours dit non
m
[Musique]
on a toujours le choix c'est juste que
j'ai jamais du courage de faire le monde
gunther en mode baby shower
on a besoin de tes talents
quelqu'un nous avo lui
qui peut être assez fou pour voler la
firme
c'est fait changement de programme ils
ont kidnappé une petite de 8 ans je la
laisserai pas mourir
ça tue à tuer les mauvaises personnes tu
n'es plus sous notre protection des
messieurs très méchant vont nous
attaquer il faut qu'on se mette à l'abri
salut mon nom je suis grand père
aulas nous
les filles je crois que je vois un
fantôme il nous faut désarmante aura
besoin d'un gène austin d'un virginia
woolf et d'un agatha christie
pour le lire
ordre de tuer
c'est notre seule chance de mettre
peintre on va leur faire tomber le ciel
sur la tête
je laisse faire un peu de bruit
bon c'est quoi le plat j'ai commandé
albert non mais tu te fous de moi non
c'est vraiment sincère
si jamais rapport vivant
je viendrai pas ni ton corps
et une tueuse en série quoi tu tues des
gens non
et tu en as tué plusieurs c'est une
série c'est plus compliqué que ça
[Musique]
oh
où sommes nous je ne reconnais pas
on n'en passe pas la salpêtrière comme
la cfdt qui n'ont pas ça
à faire ici
ça ce n'est pas toi qu'il dessine ton
père enfin c'était ton père
maintenant c'est le docteur charcot
c'est comme ça
[Musique]
bougeait pas amarré
déclenchée aux yeux se ferment vous
entendez que ma voix
est-il vrai que vous communiquer avec
les morts mademoiselle tout ça
calmez vous je me calme si je veux
nous rions
[Musique]
dans son
même dans son
où ça me forte
ça me va
ethernet
l'oms et messieurs je vous prie
maintenant d'accueillir celle que vous
attendez tous
les dames c'est à vous
est ce que vous connaissez le bord
autres auchan à l'inspecteur morin voilà
madame tranchant a reçu des lettres de
menaces de mort hier en floride a été
saboté à les ados 203 perd on lis entre
peut pas perdre audibien merguez et pas
marqué
vouziers du lourd le crime est pour ce
soir
[Musique]
c'est comme ça que ça lucic ont alors
vérifié
comme quoi quand on mène une enquête
avec méthode depuis le début le résultat
est toujours au rendez vous
café saint lô
le baron louis cocu et ça c'est un
véritable mobile leocour ont tué au cul
s'il sait pas qu'il est cocu ou et son
mobile
ah oui
[Musique]
enfin chassé pas compliqué sébastien v50
feu train il ne lui en reste plus que 32
combien gens lui en a pris mais sinon du
coup tu réfléchis pour comines
là il s'est fait chopé au lycée entre
l'édifice du mélange toi quoi mais
disent que c'est que cette histoire
encore
alors
merci alors
[Musique]
et vous vous rendez pas compte en fait
qu'est ce que je fous lancé on a
transféré nos esprits dans le corps de
quelqu'un d'autre
[Musique]
mais c'est immonde non non non rolland
team n'avait pas son permis je fais
attention tu elle vous fait des amis
confiante
[Musique]
et juste à rétro ça va
donc c'est quillard bahdja
[Musique]
il
vous inquiétez pas il ya quand même
quelque chose qui cloche non je fais
tu veux que ça reste sexuelle ça restera
on l'a fait combien de fois 37
alors les opposants
à
tu fais aussi de passe
elle avait des seringues sur m ça c'est
normal ça non est infirmière sais pas où
sa mère assise ici
[Musique]